bassam's are ridiculous and unbelievably
small a single human hair is about as
thick as 500,000 carbon atoms stacked
over each other look at your fists
it contains trillions and trillions of
atoms
if one atom in it were about as big as a
marble how big would your fists be well
about the size of Earth hmm still hard
to imagine let's try something different
[Music]
look at your little finger
imagine that its tip is as big as the
room you're sitting in right now now
fill the room with grains of rice one
rice corn represents one cell of your
fingertip now let's zoom in on the rice
corn and now one cell is as big as the
room you're in right now let's fill it
with rice again this is about the size
of a protein and now let us fill all the
empty spaces between the rice corns with
fine grains of sand this is roughly how
small atoms are what is an atom made of
let us just pretend that atoms look like
this for a minute to make it easier to
understand an atom consists of three
elementary particles neutrons protons
and electrons protons and neutrons bind
together and form the atom core held
together by the strong interaction one
of the four fundamental forces in the
universe they are made from quarks and
held together by gluons
Noli knows exactly how small quarks are
we think they might literally be points
like in geometry try to imagine them as
being zero dimensional we suspect that
quarks and electrons are the most
fundamental components of matter in the
universe electrons orbit the Azzam core
they travel at a speed of about 2,200
kilometers per second fast enough to get
around the earth in just over 18 seconds
like quarks we think electrons are
fundamental particles ninety-nine point
nine nine nine nine nine nine nine nine
nine
99% of an atom's volume is just empty
space except that it isn't what we
perceive as emptiness is actually a
space filled by quantum fluctuations
fields that have potential energy and
build and dissolve spontaneously these
fluctuations have a fundamental impact
on how charged particles interact but
that's a topic for another video how
much space to the core and electrons
actually fill if you were to subtract
all the spaces between the atom cores
from the Empire State Building it would
be about as big as a rice corn all the
atoms of humanity would fit in a
teaspoon there are extreme objects where
states like this actually exist in a
neutron star atom cores are compacted so
densely that the mass of three suns fits
into an object only a few kilometers
wide by the way what do atoms look like
well kind of like this electrons are
like a wavefunction and a particle at
the same time we can calculate where an
electron might be at any given moment in
time these clouds of probability called
orbitals are where electrons might be
with a certainty of 95% the probability
of finding an electron approaches zero
the further we get away from the atom
core but it actually never is zero which
means that in theory the electron of an
atom could be on the other side of the
universe okay wait a second these
strange thing is make up all the master
in the universe for many dozens of known
elements you don't need many dozens of
elementary particles just three take one
proton and one electron and you have
hydrogen and a proton and a neutron you
have helium and a few more you get
carbon a few more fluorine even more
gold and so on and every atom of an
element is the same all hydrogen atoms
in the universe for example are the same
the hydrogen in your body is exactly the
same as the hydrogen in the Sun do you
feel confused right now
we certainly do nothing on this scale of
the universe makes any sense in our
world and we've not even begun talking
about quantum mechanics or the particles
which are even stranger power model of
atoms has changed a number of times
since we first conceived it and the
current one will certainly not be the
last
so let us support scientists and
research and wait for the next wave of
mind-boggling new information about this
strange world that is the basis for our
existence
[Music]
you